gentlemen because of the Reese
musicians from our Greek brothers
we are obligated to read
[ __ ] hazing is fundamentally at odds
with the ideals of Phi Sigma mu hazing
runs contrary to our core concepts of
Brotherhood and is prohibited in all
forms any activities intended to produce
harassment embarrassed or blah blah blah
blah [ __ ] I will not be tolerated if
they just [ __ ] do this to weed out
the weak ones show me mean business show
me won't be here I gotta be tougher this
is Phi Sigma mu for gentlemen
we don't like to fight
but if we got a fight then we all fight
cuz we in the [ __ ] stomach
[Applause]
get a drink [ __ ]
[Music]
listen up you guys have three hours to
finish this keg if you fail I can 100%
promise you you're gonna have to [ __ ]
this goat start the music
if mom says you thinking about bailing
on school I'm not bailing on it it's
already accepted for the fall plus fine
stickers on the Russian in the fall
theater unify see I am yeah that's
awesome so what's up with Russia can
anybody come out yeah of course yeah we
actually got a party on Saturday
this is Phi Sigma V for gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm excited I'm excited you're here
these are some of the best users no
you're gonna beep I say we're gonna do
step for their lives well they're not
gonna let you in here's my brother you
need to let me know you want to be here
hello get your ugly go to the house in
11 minutes you're dead welcome to hell
we go sir our initiation is a rite of
passage take it take it
who was the first president George
Washington sir wrong drink who's shot
John F Kennedy Oh wrong drink
want honorable style there we go look I
went through this myself
right they just do this to weed out the
weak ones this pledge getting weirder
pledges got to go through hell otherwise
what's the point maybe she just quit did
if you Clint there's another guy that
couldn't hack it I'm having sex for the
first time in my life I'm not stupid
there's something cuz I mean none of
batter's at all these matters to me
but we haven't been doing anything that
every other fraternity on campus hasn't
been doing
the brothers do it we don't do we done
we don't run until we die we don't
brothers do we